dans cet épisode hardcore on va essayer
de caractériser l'ensemble des sommes
infini qui peuvent être sommé par une
super sommation ligne régulière et
stable si vous n'avez rien compris à ce
que je viens de dire je vous conseille
fortement d'aller voir l'épisode 4 de ma
série sur l'infini où j'explique comment
on peut utiliser une super formation
régulière linéaire et stable pour
trouver une valeur à la somme des
puissances de deux laquelle est alors
égale à -1
alors il s'agit d'un épisode hardcore ce
qui veut dire que je vais utiliser pas
mal de concept en fait qu'ils sont
introduits g1 en première année
d'université notamment des notions d'
espace vectoriel essaierait de faire en
temps et en heure des vidéos en dida qui
correspondent à tout ceci
mais je préfère vous prévenir que ce
dont on va parler c'est vraiment pas
facile à comprendre et il faut vraiment
une aisance avec des notions d' espace
vectoriel et puis même là en fait je
vais en arriver à la fin de cette vidéo
à des plus des conjectures que des
théorèmes puisque je n'ai pas vérifié
tout ce dont je vais parler et a même
des trucs sur lesquels je veux vraiment
pas je fais vraiment asséché équipe pour
commencer je vais m'autoriser à pointer
une erreur qui a été fait dans des
vidéos qui semble avoir démontré que 1 +
2 + 3 puisqu'à depuis 5-6 ensuite la
somme des antilles est égal à - 1 12e et
l'aide de manipulation de la linéarité
de la stabilité de la régularité des
supers sommation donc les calculs en
tant que tels sont juste sauf que dans
les commentaires d'un biais qu'avait
écrit david sur son étonnante un certain
rémi père qui a fait sa thèse avec
cédric villani dont je vous reparlerai
aussi de perry me faire si on reparle
des systèmes de vote tout dit-il coeur
et me perdre dans les commentaires du
billet de blog
david avait fait la remarque qu'en fait
si on fait s - deux aces plus s coup s
est la somme des entier on obtient une
somme qui est égal à 1 plus zéro plus
zéro plus zéro plus zéro plus zéro ce
qui suggère que s - 2 est plus s est
égal à 1
or s - deux espèces est co-60 fouet ce
qui forcément égal à zéro du coup on a
prouvé la queue 0 est égal à 1 et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a prouvé que 0
égal à 1
c'est parce qu'on a supposé que s avait
une super sommation linéaire stable et
régulière autrement dit en supposant que
l'on peut attribuer une valeur à un plus
haut depuis ce rôle puisque l'appui cinq
jeux de suite avec une super sensation
linéaire est stable et régulière on
provoque alors si on fait cela d'un
cataclysme mathématiques qui fait que
tout s'effondre la preuve deux réunis
père est juste et basta trice elle
montre que le biais de blogs de davie de
la vidéo de mick matelas les vidéos de
number five est la preuve originale de
l'air tout ça c'est faux pour sauver le
monde des mathématiques
il faut absolument considérer qu'on n'a
pas le droit de faire une super
sensation dîner régulière et stable de
la somme des entier et je rajoute que si
moi j'avais pas lu le commentaire de
rémy père ou la page wikipedia requis 2
ping bien après le commentaire de rupert
a été actualisée pour dire qu'en fait
cette super sommation linéaire stable et
régulière est en fait interdite
moi si j'avais pas lu ça va je serais
tombé dans le panneau j'aurais pu faire
une vidéo comme ça où je disais je on
avait le droit de faire cette super
sensations et je serais tombé dans le
panneau comme comme tous les autres mais
du coup tout ceci soulève une question
qu en est il de la somme de minutes
physique c'est ce que la somme des
puissances de 2 est vraiment il ya là -
est ce qu'il existe vraiment cette super
sommation est ce que cette super
sommation ligne est régulière et stable
des puissances de deux ne conduit pas
elle aussi un cataclysme des
mathématiques et plus généralement
quelles sont les super sommation
linéaire régulière et stable que l'on a
le droit ou pas le
de faire il vient cette question qu'on
va essayer de répondre dans cette vidéo
hardcore et la première étape ça
consiste à essayer de formaliser un peu
plus ce qu'on entend par une super
sommation donc en fait le super
sommation ce avec consiste à ajouter un
nombre infini de thermes des dômes au
real autrement dit c'est une fonction
qui va prendre en compte une suite réel
et qu'avec il va lui attribuer une
valeur réelle fait qu'il s'agit même
d'une forme linéaire sur l'ensemble des
suites infini alors les plus malins
d'entre vous diront qu'on peut même
généraliser sa décor qui ne sont pas
forcément dire et voire même à des
anneaux mais pour faire simple
aujourd'hui on va se construit juste sur
les nombres réels
sauf qu'en fait on a vu qu'on ne pouvait
pas super se met par exemple la somme
des entier du coup en fait va pas
pouvoir se met toutes les suites réel
une super sommation donc ça va être
plutôt une opération d'un sous-ensemble
de l'ensemble des suites réel dans
l'ensemble des réelles un peu comme
l'est la sommation classique la
sommation au classique s c'est
finalement une fonction qui va aller de
l'ensemble des suites qui donne lieu à
une série convergentes tout je vais
appeler ça c'est un pur convergent dans
l'ensemble des réels ils ensemble c est
la sommation elles sont de très bonnes
propriétés
par exemple l'espace c est un sou espace
vectoriel lui lançant des fusées ariane
c'est à dire que c'est j'ajoute deux de
suite real qui sont déjà convergentes je
vais obtenir une suite réel qui est
aussi convergentes
mieux encore on a une certaine
compatibilité entre l'addition des
suites réel terme à terme et la
formation classique
plus précisément la sommation classique
va être une formule air line et en
particulier et ça ça veut dire que si je
prends de suite
dans l'ensemble c'est et si je prends
dorée elle lambda ému alors la sommation
de lambda mu plus buvez pas être égal à
lambda pour la sommation de vue plus lui
faut la sommation de v on a aussi un
endomorphisme linéaire important qui que
je vais appeler eux
il consiste à rajouter 1 0 autrement dit
si la suite humaine c'est une deux trois
oscars
suite eu de hull va être égal à 0 hull 2
0 etc
enfin il ya une relation assez agréable
entre eux et est ce qu est le fait que
si j'arrive d'un zéro jeu n'a fait que
personne autrement dit s2e2 huet et
gallèse vue pour tout de suite
une de ces j'espère que jusque là tout
va bien tout ce que j'ai fait ici c'est
redire en un langage un peu plus
mathématiques âgée briest des trucs qui
sont vraiment assez triviaux mais ce
langage qu'on va utiliser va être en
fait extrêmement utile pour la suite
parce que ce qu'on veut vraiment fait en
fait quand on définit une super
sommation c'est définir une fonction t
qui va aller ensemble h2r ou âge est un
sou espace vectoriel d'un sont des
suites réel mais un sur espace vectoriel
c'est-à-dire qui contient l'ensemble des
suites c'est qu'ils donnent lieu à des
séries convergentes il le fait que la
super sommation t.aer linéaire régulière
et stable ça veut dire que tu es est une
forme hier déjà et ensuite que tu es 2e
de huet et galatée de eu pour tout eu
cette fois appartenant à l'ensemble h et
enfin la régularité correspond à la dire
que si je prends une suite lui qui
énonce et qui était qui donne lieu donc
à une série convergentes
alors la valeur tu es 2e doit être égale
à la valeur s ii u qu'on avait calculé
avec une sommation classique donc
idéalement ce que j'aimerais faire c'est
prendre le h au plus grand possible donc
le h ou plus courant sous espace
vectoriel de l'ensemble des suites riel
pour lesquelles je peux construire une
telle valeur pour t'es où t'es est
forcément défini de façon unique
mais avant d'en arriver là qu'on va
commencer par y aller par petits pas
essayer ou v l'existence et l'unicité
d'une super sommation pour la suite deux
minutes physique ce roman dit qu'on va
considérer l'ensemble h qui est
l'ensemble des suites qui donne lieu à
une série convergentes plus de puissance
une fois air d'options sénat c'est ce
que l'on entend par deux pieds en scène
c'est la suite des deux puissances end
et puissance de 2 et x r parce qu'on va
en faire un espace vectoriel donc faucon
admettre aussi les multiplications de
cette suite par une constante parce
qu'on veut aussi pouvoir ajouter une
suite dont la série convergentes
à la suite des deux puissances n donc en
terme de
espace vectoriel vous n'avez cessé car
un espace virtuel de très grandes
dimensions et on a un autre sous l'eau
espace vectoriel de puissance n fois air
qui lui est un espace vectoriel deux
dimensions 1 et on voit que ces deux
essais sont forcément sommes direct
puisque depuis en scène n'est pas une
suite de ces dernières choses qui nous
faut vérifier c'est que h l'ensemble
qu'on a construit ici et bien stable par
l'application 2e en particulier pour
prouver ça comme on sait que c'est déjà
stable par application de e
il faut que eu de la suite depuis son
sen soit quelque chose qui soit encore
dans l'ensemble h
or on sait qu'on a eu deux de la suite
de puissance n qui est égale à la suite
11 01 de 4,8 et c est bien cette suite
c'est la moitié de la suite
u2 elle-même donc un demi de la suite de
deux puissances elles-mêmes
donc c'est un demi fois la suite des
deux puissances n - vous rajoutez un
premier terme là pour enlever la
première coordonnées et donc ça revient
à faire - la suite 1/2 00 00 or la suite
- 1/2 00 00 ça c'est bien une suite qui
donne une série convergentes un homme de
sa de tous ces termes ça ferait moins un
demi donc on a bien écrit eu de la suite
de puissance n comme une somme d'un
élément qui est proportionnelle à deux
pistons scène la suite de puissance n
plus une suite qui appartient à ces et
donc ashley bien stable par
l'application linéaire eux et ça ça veut
dire aussi que si on veut définir t sur
l'ensemble est tout entier comme on
connaît déjà la valeur de t sur ces il
nous reste plus qu'à déterminer la
valeur de t pour l' espace vectoriel qui
en somme direct
c'est à dire pour en fait de puissance
elle si on détermine la valeur de t pour
la suite des deux puissances n alors on
aura déterminé la valeur de t sur tout
l'ensemble h sauf qu'on a une condition
à vérifier pour que tes soit vraiment
une super sommation ligne régulière et
stable
il faut que tu es 2e de deux puissants
cents soit égal à thé de deux puissances
n or on a vu comment il se fait mais eux
deux puissances n en fonction de deux
puissants scène de suite depuis en scène
et d'un terme convergent et ça ça
implique que tu es de deux puissances n
est égal à 1,2 me de thé de deux
puissances n - 1/2 et ça si on leur a
écrit ça impose que tu es 2 2 puis en
scène est égale 1 - 1
et ça ça montre l'unicité de la valeur
possible de thé maintenant si on fixe et
cette valeur à tes de deux puces en
scène
on a construit notre application
linéaire votre faim hier mais on peut
vérifier qu'elles vérifient toutes les
bonnes propriétés qu'on avait imposé
donc là on a montré l'existence de cette
super sommation guinée est régulière et
stable et en particulier on a montré
qu'il n'y avait pas d' inconsistance qui
venait du fait d'imposer la valeur - 1 à
la suite à la somme de mini de physx
notamment si on prend une suite h de
l'espace grand h
alors on sait qu'on peut écrire de façon
unique h comme la somme d'une suite dont
la série convergentes c est de alpha
fois depuis en scène la suite des deux
puissances m du coup la valeur qui va
être attribué à la suite h sera
forcément tdah est égal à t2c plus alpha
fois tu es de la suite de puissance n
par régularité on sait que t2c est égal
à s ii c et on vient de calculer que tu
es de deux puissances n est égal à moins
un an donc dès 2h et forcément idéal ss2
c - alpha est en fait la construction
que je viens de faire ici peuvent être
généralisées à toutes les suites
géométriques divergentes
sauf le cas où le terme multiplicatif de
la suite géométriques et un en effet
plus généralement si on prend la suite x
puissance n
alors on a eu 2 x puissance
n qui est égal à 1 sur x x x puissance n
plus la suite moins un sur x 0 0 0 0 0
et ça ça impose que tu es 2 x puissance
n va être égal à 1 surexploités ii x6 en
scène - 1 sur x ce qui impose que tu es
2x plus en scène est égal à 1 sur un
mois x est où ce raisonnement il ne peut
marcher que si on suppose qu'ils x est
différent de 1
petite remarque pour ceux d'entre vous
qui après des suites géométriques au
lycée ou à l'université
la preuve que je me donnais est
exactement la même en fait que la preuve
pour la sommation des suites
géométriques convergentes suis là j'ai
juste étendu ensuite géométriques
divergent c'est à dire où la valeur
absolue de x va être supérieur ou égal à
1 mais x est différent de donc ce que je
viens de dire permet en fait d'étendre
définition de thé à l' espace vectoriel
h qui est égal à l'ensemble c'est plus
en somme direct la somme d espace
vectoriel qui s'écrivent x puissance n
pour des valeurs de x qui sont à
l'extérieur de moins-11
pour être un peu plus explicite cela
correspond à des valeurs pour x
appartenant à moins l'infini
- 1 union 1 ouvert plus infinie super
cool on vient de prouver que non
seulement la preuve deux minutes physx
peut être formalisée être rigoureuse
mais en plus on a prouvé qu'elle pouvait
être généralisé à toutes les suites
géométriques qui donne lieu à des séries
divergentes
sauf pour coefficient multiplicateur qui
est égale à la question qui vient après
c'est bien sûr qu est-ce qu on peut
généraliser c'est ce qu'on peut aller
plus loin alors vous êtes peut-être
senti que la clé du raisonnement c'était
le fait que lorsque j terré eux à des
suites divergentes
je vous retombez sur l'aspect original
plus assez une certaine série convergent
et c'est un peu la clé de tout le
raisonnement que je vais poursuivre dans
la suite
en fait je vais considérer des suites
tels que si je fais c'est plus espace
vectoriel engendrés par les e puissance
qu'a appliqué à la suite pu alors
j'obtiens le même espace vectoriel que
c'est plus l'espace vectorielle
engendrée par une 2e quart et de vue etc
jusqu'à un certain appui 100 cède -1 2 u
ça ça va me permettre d'avoir un espace
vectoriel qui sur lequel je définis en
fonction tai chi et de dimensions fini
et ça va me permettre notamment de
déterminer à la main quelle est la
valeur que je dois attribué à la suite
une en particulier ça va me permettre de
garantir l'unicité de la valeur que je
peux attribuer à la suite ou avec une
super formation alignée régulière et
stable par le fait que ces deux espace
vectoriel sont les mêmes ça revient à
dire que pour tout cas le n cars 2 u va
être égale à une certaine combinaison
linéaire du terme ces cas de la suite de
c est d eux j de u2 cas ce qui
correspond à dire qu'on a une certaine
récurrence linéaire ou plus exactement
le fait que u2 n puisqu'à est égal à un
certain c'est le cas plus une
combinaison linéaire nkaké koffi sens
que je veux appeler à 0 2 k plus à 2 1
u2 capucins et ainsi de suite jusqu'à
a2l -1 eu de cas plus elles - 1
si on oublie de termes ces deux cas on
aurait là une suite défini par
récurrence linéaire donc on peut dire
que les suites où il ya le ces deux cas
sont des suites défini par récurrence
linéaire à une caméra convergentes et
qui correspond à ces deux cas nous faut
maintenant déterminer la valeur de t d
une valeur de tde on peut la déduire de
l'équation qui relie le puy en scène ou
aux absences j2ee eu pour j entre 0 et 3
1 donc quand la piquante et des deux
côtés on obtient td eut été galatée de
ses plus la somme des rares fois tu es
devenu ce que l'on peut réécrire comme
étant t2 huet et galatée de ces divise
et pas à 1 - assomme des ados carré pour
qu'on ait le droit de faire ça il faut
absolument que la somme des rica soit
différente de 1
en fait si la somme de laquelle est pas
différente de 1 soit on ne peut pas
définir tait soit on a une infinité de
façon de définir t ce qui pose problème
du coup la seule façon que l'on puisse
définir et que l'on puisse définir
uniquement une valeur pour telus
c'est le cas où le sound et aka donc les
coefficients de la récurrence et
différentes 2 1
autrement dit chaque nouveau terme de la
suite ne doit pas être presqu'un
barycentre des termes précédent donc
typiquement à la suite qui n'a que des 1
il ya une fuite géométriques avec un
coefficient qui est égal à 1
ça c'est une suite où chaque élément est
une moyenne du précédent en fait il est
égal au précédent et c'est pour ça que
cette suite là ne peuvent allure et
sociale de super sommation régulière
lignières et stable de la même façon et
peut-être un peu plus triki on à la
suite des entiers positif qui a une
suite où chaque terme est embarrassante
des deux termes précédent avec des
coefficients 2 et - 1 et comme 2 - 1 est
égal à 1 la suite les antilles est
positif est une suite c'est où chaque
terme est à peu près le barycentre à une
suite conversion de près des éléments
précédents
et si on oublie ses suites il semble que
toutes les suites définissable à
récurrence linéaire qui n'est pas un
barycentre des coefficients de pré
saison et qui est défini à une erreur
convergentes près il semble que tout de
suite ses suites là peuvent être super
sonné alors il faudrait un petit peu
plus rigoureux et je n'ai pas été parce
que parce que pour qu'on ait le droit
vraiment de rajouter ses valeurs il faut
que les éléments de la suite soit dans
un espace vectoriel qui est en somme
direct avec l'espace factuelle de base
qu'elles ont recherché la rajouter et
c'est pas le cas en fait parce qu'on
peut avoir des suites qui donne lieu à
des séries
mais on peut faire remarque que pour les
suites qui a été déjà convergentes la
relation qu'on a déduit du fait que
puissance n 2 s'est exprimée en fonction
d'eux d'autres termes est alors une
relation entre suite convergentes et du
coup la valeur qu'on impose à la suite
n'est pas un francis tente avec la
formation classique parce qu'on sait que
la sommation classique et linéaire est
stable dernière question que l'on peut
se poser c'est est ce que l'on n'a dans
cette construction inclut toutes les
suites auquel on peut assigner de façon
unique une et le et non inconsistante
une super sommation linéaire régulière
et stable et il me semble que oui mais
j'en ai pas la preuve formelle j'ai
peut-être pas assez réfléchi
du coup j invite les plus matheux
essayer de prouver la conjecture heures
suivantes
l'ensemble des séries pour lesquels on
peut définir une unique super sommation
linéaire régulière et stable et
l'ensemble des suites dont les termes
peuvent être définies par une récurrence
linéaire qui n'est pas un baril centre a
eu une erreur convergentes prêt s'il ya
des courageux parmi vous vous invite à
essayer de m'envoyer un pdf ou indiens
sur internet et je mettrai un lien vers
votre preuve là où la place est dans les
descriptions de cette vidéo